hello everybody uh hell man I haven't
done one of these videos in a minute too
every time I do this I always say that
and I don't know why it's important for
me to you shut the [ __ ] up David you
shut up you shut up now hey what is
going on ya [ __ ] butt sniffing
creatures s right don't don't get to
know people that way I tried it's
pinkeye we're just gonna get right into
this there's a movie coming out real
soon or actually it'll probably will
already have come out by the time I
released this video whatever they crazy
rich hey now I wanted to bring up this
video because you know it's it's kind of
hard to deny it like the the effect and
the movement that this film is having
specifically not only in Hollywood but
within the Asian community now before I
go ahead and get into the meat of this
film I do want to address something
that's really been on my mind I kind of
something that I really disliked David
um about something he dislikes is that
[ __ ] you probably not while you
watching this channel then [ __ ] now
before this film came out I kept
carrying the same rhetoric over and over
and it was something along the lines of
if you don't go watch this film that
means you don't support Asian people
okay [ __ ] first of all don't be telling
people what to do I'll do you don't tell
you don't tell me what to do and the
conversation that was being you know
developed with this not only on the
positive side was if you don't watch
this film that means you don't care
that's right [ __ ] you got it all
figured out if I don't want to watch a
movie that means I don't like Asian
people you useless piece of [ __ ] I'm
gonna put this out there if you are an
Asian American person and you're trying
to have a conversation with someone me
or other Asian American people on
YouTube is saying that we're not doing
our part [ __ ] what the [ __ ] do you
think we have been doing for the past
like seven to ten years what what and so
before this film even came out it was
already putting like this negative thing
on it for somebody like me because of
how the approach was you have to watch
this because you're Asian and I don't
think that's a very good look for Asian
Americans or Asian American films
because for me I want this film to do
super [ __ ] well but I wanted to do
well because the film is also amazing
and to say that you want me to have an
opinion about something before I even
give it a chance I think is [ __ ]
dumped let me wash the
film when I want to watch it and I can
give it my full [ __ ] attention I don't
know if you've noticed or if you [ __ ]
know me telling me that I have to do
something probably isn't the best
[ __ ] idea I'm a [ __ ] immigrant
Asian stand-up comedian I don't think my
parents telling me that I had to become
a businessman or a doctor was really
going to sink in what the [ __ ] you think
you're going to do to influence me to do
anything [ __ ]
you may gonna spank me in my bootie
unless you a financial now having said
all that am I going to watch the film
Oh hundred [ __ ] percent yes of course
I'm gonna watch crazy rich Asians of
course I'm going to buy a [ __ ] ticket
people have even asked me the why don't
you go buy out a whole theater oh [ __ ]
am i I don't know what it is maybe it's
the Internet's that you guys think that
I'm ballin out of my [ __ ] mind and
I'm not by a whole theater but that's
what all these other Asian celebrities
are doing Oh John Cho or Sir John do I
look like Joe to you [ __ ] I'm David so
the hell I look at my menu I don't even
look at the [ __ ] food first [ __ ] I
look at the dollar sign [ __ ]
that's Asian crazy broke Asian that's my
new film I still gotta suck a dick
number that's how you know you're poor I
know I'm not gonna buy a whole [ __ ]
theater out I'm sorry I ain't got it
like debt and if I did buying a whole
theater out of tickets is the most
uneven thing to do I don't know what
you're talking about the Asian to buy
those tickets and sell it to somebody
for two dollars more expensive that's
the that's the Asian way I'm gonna go
watch this film despite how people think
I should react to it how I should
support it I'm gonna go watch it simply
because of this this film has become
more than just the film do you
understand what I'm saying
this film has become such an iconic
moment I think for a lot of Asian
Americans who want to go into
entertainment beyond the point of this
is not my type of film it's not about
that I'm still gonna have opinions about
it if I don't like the film and if I
don't want to watch it again however
what I can do is at least purchase this
ticket because I feel like with this
film because of all the attention that
is getting and we needed to do well in
the box office we need to prove to
Hollywood and we need to prove to people
who out there who want entertainment
from Asian Americans that we are able to
produce content out there that people
will watch that has been the biggest
struggle because a lot of the
times when it came to like creating
content people will say oh well we need
a white face to it you know I understand
whatever that's how the rhetoric in
Hollywood has been but there are a lot
of asian-americans out there and if we
don't support the films that we want to
tell our story however even if it
doesn't relate to your specific
asian-american story it's going to open
doors for you later on in the future
once again it's not about is it your
type of film it's put your [ __ ] money
where your [ __ ] mouth is you see
people on Twitter bro-bro sees your
Asian American representation oh I don't
get this chance well how about you now
shut the [ __ ] up and put your money
where your [ __ ] mouth is I'm going to
do it and I'm the biggest hater of all I
hate [ __ ] all the [ __ ] time not about
like whether it was like well did these
Asian Americans support you when you put
out [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] if they did
or not I I really don't [ __ ] care I
mean there was a lot of support it
didn't have the same support as crazy
rich Asians because crazy rich Asians
it's like oh it's a [ __ ] hugely
funded film and it needs to do well but
it also shines light on what we do as
well you know Justin did an amazing job
on that [ __ ] film and I think that
dude deserves the highest accolades for
creating something that not only was it
a black and white film not only was it a
period piece not only did it speak in
volumes but it was something that you
know related to me as an asian-american
kid growing up and I'll say it one more
[ __ ] time once again it's not about
whether it's your type of film or not
think about the positive effect that is
going to have if you put your [ __ ]
money where your mouth is and you
purchase a ticket to watch this film
have your opinions about it and whatever
but at least give this film a chance
you're asking how I came to this
conclusion to I had to do a little bit
of reflecting because to be straight-up
honest with you when I saw the crazy
rich asian film trailer I was like I'm
trying to watch this [ __ ] [ __ ]
specifically because it's a rom-com and
I don't know if I've ever really liked a
Jon M Chu film you know I'm saying not
not to say that I don't [ __ ] with Jon M
Chu or or any of the cast members it's
just like I don't [ __ ] like rob cons
and I'm allowed to have that [ __ ]
opinion but I had to think outside the
box and I had to really think about what
this film is going to do and what it
really is about and actually what I
really thought about was when I was
first on JK news and I was telling these
stories especially it like my
perspective
like how racism is in America and now I
grew up in Sacramento California which
is extremely culturally diverse and I
did have a few like racist moments here
and there but it wasn't anywhere near as
bad as other people's experiences and
they would tell me stuff like oh yeah
like well you know racism like I is
still alive you know I felt that
everyday growing up but I'm like for me
like I was very dismissive of it because
of my situation that I grew up in so
just because my experience was like that
growing up it doesn't mean that it was
for everybody else and how I'm tying
this back into the support of crazy rich
Asians crazy rich Asians talks about an
Asian American story that I don't
[ __ ] know about rich Asian people I
grew up with some gutter ass
[ __ ] Asian folks we were broke
as [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm telling you man we
will go to [ __ ] Taco Tuesday for del
Taco just because that was the [ __ ]
meal that we could have you thought that
were those tacos delicious if you
sponsor me they're the best tacos I've
ever had this film is not supposed to
represent every [ __ ] Asian person
upbringing you know that is their [ __ ]
that's the spectrum of a culture right
it's not just one [ __ ] thing so for
those people out there that are saying
like you know this isn't the real Asian
American experience that's your
experience this you're doing the same
[ __ ] that I used to do there are so many
different stories and pockets as the
rich Asian people there's the [ __ ]
gut ass broke-ass [ __ ] Asian people
there's the [ __ ] immigrant story like
you saw like your [ __ ] and [ __ ] there's
there's so many it's a spectrum you know
what I'm saying so if you feel
apprehensive about watching this film
reflect upon what it's going to do for
us as people and the film industry in
general and go out there and support it
with your dollars that's all I'm saying
and I'll let this come from any game
itself come on the Jeff support group I
hope you did you useless piece of [ __ ]